This episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream.
What's up wisecrack Michael here.
You may have heard me on our rick and
Morty podcast where much to my dismay,
jared has dubbed me Dr.
Nihilism.
I've also written some videos you might
recognize like are always sunny episode,
the gaze of the abyss episode,
the philosophy of get out and more
recently our Kayfabe episode.
Today we're continuing our discussion on
the only defense attorney who breaks the
law more often than Michael Cohen,
daredevil,
Matthew Murdoch's Catholicism,
has always been a defining element of
his character and his distinguished him
from most other nonreligious
superheroes,
but it's in this most recent season that
Catholicism comes front and center to
understand matthew struggle and why we
think season three is so awesome.
We'll have to dive into one of the most
important questions that theologians
have been struggling with for Millennia.
So join us as we break down how the man
without fear that comes the man without
faith in this wise crack.
Quick take on daredevil season three and
of course spoilers ahead.
First,
a quick recap,
some months after the events of
defenders,
but presumably before the children of
faint I was double parked their donut
chip in Greenwich Village,
Matt Murdock Awakens from a coma and the
church run orphanage he was raised in.
While the worst of his injuries have
healed,
his spirit remains broken.
Daredevil is convinced that his crusade
against injustice had ultimately failed.
As such,
he takes up residence in the chapel,
undercroft retreating from society and
allowing his public persona to remain
dead to the world.
This makeshift bat cave services one of
the primary set pieces for the season
and that constant conversations between
Murdoch,
fatherland and sister Maggie drive.
Much of the engagement with maths,
Catholic faith,
or rather the lack thereof like lex
luther and Batman versus Superman.
Daredevil is blinded by the problem of
evil,
which lex summarizes as God is all
powerful,
cannot be all good,
and it's all good and he can not be all
powerful.
In one scene,
Murdoch in Paris has seemingly senseless
suffering to that of Joe Story,
of God's perfect servant job prayed
everyday,
dawn with his knees on the ground and is
facing the third slot of 10 goats,
one for each of his children,
burn them at the alter in God's honor,
follow God soldiers.
Joe,
he was the most loyal.
I know the story I met you and know what
happens next,
gotten murdered.
All 10 of his children in cold blood
scorched every inch of job's land lashed
at his body to his skin was covered in
bloody welts.
God range misery on the life of his most
perfect servant and still job and not
cursing what I realized Joe was a pussy.
Matt wonders why God would not similarly
speak to him whether God had really
called him to the vocation of vigilante
and whether God had brought about good
through the devil of Hell's kitchen.
Unlike the steadfastly faithful job,
murdoch comes to the that God is not
good.
You might hate God right now,
but the feeling is not mutual.
No,
I don't hate him.
I've just seen as true face as all and
from the way things are going,
it seems like he's not wrong.
Throughout the season.
More and more evidence mounts for God's
indifference society seems irredeemably
corrupt entirely under the control of
Wilson Fisk,
fisk bribes and black males,
cops,
feds,
lawyers,
judges and jurist,
turning good citizens into criminals,
law enforcers into lawbreakers,
and the very institutions devoted to
justice into instruments of injustice,
given daredevils,
Catholicism.
It's after recall the words of Jesus.
Do not fear those who can kill the body
but cannot kill the soul.
Rather fear Him who can destroy both
body and soul.
You know fisk in a nutshell.
Oh,
and we can't not mention the fact that
this overweight and ostentatious New
York real estate developer who's
basically above the law suddenly takes
up residence and a presidential hotel,
not so subtle.
Marvel daredevils,
new founders,
so theism.
That is his anger and frustration at God
amplifies his disgust with humanity.
Thank Godfrey.
He didn't help you.
I did.
He abuses his friends and is generally
less interested in saving society.
Then punching it in the face.
Murdoch's broken relationships with both
God and the people around him can be
cast in Catholic terms as a failure to
do what Jesus called the two greatest
commandments,
to love God and to love your neighbor as
yourself,
but this itself isn't unique to any
specific religion.
These two relationships represent the
two basic axes which believers of most
religions have to concern themselves
with.
When deciding how to navigate life is
specially when sacred and secular duties
seem to make different demands.
It's here that Matthew directly
confronts an issue Christianity has
dealt with for centuries.
How does one reconcile and obligation to
God and an obligation to others is
specially if there's others exist in a
tainted,
a moral world or in Christian parlance
to be in the world but not of the world.
Theologian h dot Richard Niebuhr in his
book,
Christ and culture identify several
basic answers that Christians have
offered over the centuries for how to do
so,
and while he is specifically concerned
with Christianity,
his paradigm would mostly work within
any religious tradition.
Briefly,
they can be called one separation to
accommodation,
free synthesis for paradox and five,
transformation daredevils,
Arkin season three season transition
between two of these models for figuring
out our relationship to God and man,
separation and synthesis,
the former,
which Niebuhr also calls Christ against
culture,
prescribes a radical renunciation of end
near total separation from the
surrounding society.
This is the path ascribed to you by
monks and Mennonites.
It's also exactly what daredevil does in
the early when like the rest of us
millennials,
he moves back.
Home is a grown ass adult to mooch off
his parents living in their basement and
having his mom cleaned his laundry.
Yes,
really,
and like a medieval monk,
he's literally cloistered himself in a
church.
He treats his identity of Matthew
Murdoch as dead to the world and
spirits,
his friendships with foggy and Karen,
when they find out he is alive,
he pushes them away,
lies to them,
steals from them,
and treats them as mere instruments of
his agenda.
As daredevil has mat in the friend
lately without a doubt,
but deep down,
I think it's hurting him as much as it's
hurting us,
is only engagement with the world is
when he's punching it with his fist,
which is one way to construe being
against culture neighbor while affirming
that each of his five models was
partially correct and it times the
appropriate answer,
nevertheless,
was particularly critical of the
separation model as overly simplistic
and ultimately futile.
No one can completely closed themselves
off to the outside world as daredevil
discovered the hard way when Bullseye
attack,
St Patrick's.
It's the turning point of the season and
particularly poignant and it's Catholic
imagery,
all of which make clear to murdoch that
this separation model doesn't succeed in
either serving his neighbors or the man
upstairs.
First bullseyes eyes attack is a
violation of the long established norm
of sanctuary.
Karen page had sought safety there from
the retribution of Wilson Fisk and by
conspiring to murder her there kingpin
and Bullseye committed particularly
agregious sin in the eyes of Catholics
who see violence on consecrated grounds
as profaning something sacred.
Then there's the murder itself,
fatherland some sacrifices his own life
upon the altar,
saving Karen's his death is an
unmistakable illusion to Christ claim I
am the good shepherd.
I lay down my life for the sheep pastor,
deriving from the Latin for Shepard
bullseyes diabolical attack,
his violation of sanctuary and his
martyrdom of father Lantam are all proof
positive to murdoch.
That is flirtation with the for
separation model is a failure.
It's at this point that he [inaudible]
the uniquely Catholic way of
understanding how to deal with both God
and the world which kneeboard calls this
synthesis model.
The synthesis model affirms that both
the Sacred Institution of the church and
the secular institutions of society are
both means through which God brings
about good.
That includes the government as a means
of bringing about justice,
daredevils,
embrace of the separation model,
and the first half of the season
coincided with his disillusionment with
the legal system.
He become convinced that the courts
couldn't successfully serve as God's
means for enacting justice against
criminals such as fisk.
So when he later reconnects with his
friends and with them,
uses the legal system to put kingpin
back behind bars.
We can see how it's a step towards
affirming this synthesis model.
Of course,
Murdoch's returned to the fold.
It doesn't happen all at once,
and daredevil tempted up until the
climactic fight to kill the kingpin.
But whereas in the first season,
his temptation to finish off fisk was
simply a struggle with the deadly sin of
Wrath.
Here it indicates Murdoch is still
questioning whether God is using social
institutions to bring about good or
whether daredevil has to take matters
into his own hands.
At this point,
Murdoch has rejected the separation,
just approach,
but it's not until the redemption of
reign of diem that he wants again,
fully affirms the Catholic approach of
synthesis.
Since the show start,
Murdoch's core conviction has been that
no one was past the point of redemption.
Batman has his personal code against
killing that's informed by the murder of
his parents,
but despite sharing a similar origin,
the show is clear that read Batman,
scruples came from his Catholic faith
for Murdoch.
It'd be a moral to execute his enemies
because he held hope that even someone
so sinful as Wilson fisk might have a
change of heart and repent,
but it's not until this season that a
character that had broke bad is shown to
go good.
Once again.
FBI special agent reign of Diem is one
of the many government officials
blackmailed by FIS in addition to other
crimes.
Nadeem is the accomplished a eyes
bullseyes murder of father Atlanta,
and yet he's not beyond redemption.
Nadeem agrees to testify against fisk
knowing full well the danger of crossing
his crime boss,
and when fisk gets to the grand jury,
making the turncoats testimony.
Feudal Nadeem instead of running
voluntarily lays down his life so that
his dying deposition would send the king
pin back to prison.
And this is what finally restores Matt
Murdock's.
Faith seeing God appear to work,
redemption in human hearts and justice
through social institutions.
Not separately,
but in synthesis with one another to
bring about good in the world.
This is the ultimate example of
kneeboards synthesis,
the vertical relationship to God and the
horizontal relationship with man working
together,
the Vertical Relationship Aka Nadine's
conscience.
Getting to tuned is the thing which
allows the horizontal relationship,
Aka Society,
including institutions such as the legal
system to be the means by which God
brings about justice.
The two are working together in
synthesis and without the vertical.
The horizontal would have failed.
The season ends with Murdoch having come
through his crisis of faith.
He's no longer sequestered away from
society and the church basement,
but preaching from the pulpit to his
whole community.
He's no longer a strange from his
friends,
but getting the gang back together in
the form of Nelson Murdoch and paige
attorneys at law and he's no longer
blind to is God's goodness,
but trying to see as much of it as
possible.
Thanks for watching guys,
but before you go,
this episode is brought to you by
curiosity stream in amazing subscription
streaming service that offers over 2000
documentaries and nonfiction titles.
Curiositystream features content made by
some of the world's greatest filmmakers,
including exclusive originals.
It's the perfect way to enhance your
knowledge about the complicated world
around us and to impress your friends at
dinner parties.
Curiosity Stream is the Goto streaming
service for nonfiction entertainment.
If you enjoyed our take on daredevils,
theological undertones,
or any of our videos for that matter,
then you should definitely check out the
curiositystream original series curious
minds philosophy.
Each episode unpacks a philosophical
question and give some insight into the
ideas we often reference here at wise
crack.
What makes curiositystream unique is its
devotion to fulfilling our lifelong
quest to learn,
explore,
and understand the world,
and most of their incredible content is
available worldwide on a variety of
popular platforms like Roku,
Amazon,
apple TV,
xbox one,
and more.
You can get unlimited access starting at
just two $99 a month,
and wisecrack fans get the first 30 days
on curiositystream totally free when you
sign up@curiositystream.com
slash wise crack and use the Promo Code
wisecrack.
Thanks again,
Dr.
Nihilism out.